the jurgen experience the community of
people that are obsessed with the jfk
thank god it's pretty cool there's a lot
of nut cases yeah out there but those
serious people are really good and
they're the ones that kept this case
alive well it's a thing that a
conspiracy theorist really looks to i
don't use that word i think true seeker
is much more okay well forget about that
that word but someone who's interested
in uncovering the truth about this
assassination the the the type of person
that has that mindset that's interested
in uncovering the truth about any
historical that's correct this is one of
the best ones that's because there's
what a historian does yes there's
significant evidence and there's
significant evidence that there is a
conspiracy
significance i mean i would say from the
beginning there was yes when you have a
shot from the rear and a shot yes well i
was going to get into that so when you
detail
so brilliantly in this documentary
all of the people that were involved in
manipulating evidence whether it's
autopsy photos whether it's the uh the
evidence about the actual shots where
they were fired from the impact like
where the exit wounds was all these
various
people that were involved how many
people
knew what had actually happened because
it seems like
there was a
a concentration of people that was not
small and one of the things that people
who uh
like to uh
use the pejorative term uh conspiracy
theorist they always want to point to
people can't keep a secret well the [ __ ]
they can't
they had to it's a giant maze it's so
confusing yes that no one would be
believed if they were right one part
think of it as a department of this uh
departments of this somebody pops up and
says i know this
so he disappears in the maze it's
another piece of information yeah
there's been no attempt by government to
follow up on this at all they dismissed
they had the hsca in 1978 right that
came about because of pressure
and a lot of that was classified still
and disappeared for a while we got it
out
all that stuff they they decided that
there was a probable conspiracy based on
the
acoustic evidence of the motorcycles but
we don't want to go into that because
that's a whole other story acoustic
evidence from sound from the
pre-recording in the front yes
yeah well the shots the shots the the
physical evidence of the the impact on
the body is
that's more important way more important
and way more obvious
that
first of all the establishment of the
magic bullet was one of the most
preposterous things that the united
states public has ever accepted and i
think we did a great service by driving
a stake through that heart of that
vampire because it's been around forever
well you detailed in so many different
ways too you detailed all the various
ways that they had tried to establish it
once they found the wound in the back
they tried to establish don't confuse it
first of all the magic bullet there's no
chain of custody on it the fbi lied and
we proved it in the film yes you did
because
the times don't match right when it was
given so the fbi down and out lied
now hoover of course uh never beli you
know one had to believe wanted to
believe that oswalt
did it alone he had to because they put
themselves in a straitjacket they said
three shots they won not three shots it
was probably four or five shots
three shots one assassin who why what's
his motive
he was a perfectly reasonable young man
he was in the corridor being yelled at
and he said i need a lawyer i'm a
passion yes yes you know the guy didn't
behave like he was proud of what he had
done no this is what he they said he was
a communist
an assassin who they had this
background of visiting russia
of course we found out they we found out
the the community found out that it
wasn't everything what didn't meet the
eye it was a whole other story going on
what about the years old had been an
associated with the cia
not that he'd been an agent but he'd
been watched by the cia for four years
that we know without a doubt now because
of what we declassified
angleton james angleton the
counter-terrorist chief had
had a file on a oswald since before
russia
they knew him
they knew what he was doing up until the
week well apparently he just they
disappeared his flash warning about a
week before the assassination which
means to say you don't need to check
oswalt
if you're a secret service you see him
somewhere on a on a parade route you'd
have to clear out those type of people
they get
this secret service is very aware of
people who have backgrounds who could be
dangerous
they took that off the the signal on
oswald
the other thing is that oswald was
working both sides clearly that he was
working with a pro castro and the
anti-movement but the ci set up both
yeah you see i set up the pro and the
cover right
so it's it's very clear that they were
they were well aware of him dip him in
the cube and poison sheep dip him make
him look like a commie who loves castro
that was the intention i believe i
believe that the cia was so upset about
these two
near invasions of cuba that they this
was a chance by killian kennedy to get
the united states to move against castro
and this is what johnson this is where
johnson is not you can't blame johnson
because he felt that there was his
pressure right away and he said to
the warren commission guys he said look
there's a lot of pressure to point the
finger at russia and china and russia
and cuba we don't want to do that
because we're going to have a nuclear
war if we do that like 40 million people
are going to be dying that's what he
told warren warren was went white you
know in those days it was very serious
40 million people my god he had all the
weight of the country on his shoulders
and that's why he accepted this lousy
job as the chief commissioner
so johnson used that story but johnson
believed
i think he believed it i think he
there was i think he believed in some
way i'm not sure
he let me put something that's very
important marvin watson was his
aide to johnson
in 1970
uh in 19 this church committee he
testified
he testified that johnson after he read
the ig report that we talked about
earlier which said
that uh
which said that uh there were no
assassination that president kennedy or
robert had never approved authorized any
presidential any assassination attempt
on castro right he read that report and
he told watson according to watson
he said
i now believe it's the ci was probably
involved in the assassination that's
what he said wow
in 67 when he read the report wow it
comes out in the at the church committee
which is classified disappears for some
reason we find it
we find it again in because of this
ar rb so he was probably left in the
dark as well
i do believe so i think i think he's
definitely involved in the cover-up
because he doesn't want us he doesn't
want to have a war
right but he changes the whole policy of
kennedy right away he's he we have that
declassified call between him and robert
rachnamer what does johnson say in that
call do you remember it's in the film he
says
you know i was never in agreement with
you and the president about withdrawing
from vietnam
i thought you were wrong
he says that proudly yeah because he's
going in right
why he wants to go into vietnam and not
cuba you know is is another issue but
think about that just think about the
implications of it
johnson is moving towards war in vietnam
and how deep in that he i mean he was
looking to do something to weaken the
grip of the cia not just get rid of
those three guys but he also wanted to
diminish the cia's influence yeah but
that wasn't his only thought he had a
hundred things to deal with right that's
the problem right and newly in office
well yeah by 60
he said statements about the generals he
said you know they're not worth a bucket
of piss or whatever it was you know
they're not
generals think they know everything they
always want to go to war they want to
they want the parades but they don't
want the
they don't want the casualties they
don't want the result
and that's true for the united states we
go to war with a lot of
a lot of hoopla and we come out we leave
our people
we leave our people who go over there
and in mostly in very difficult states
you know either suicide or in veterans
hospitals with limbs blown off it's not
fun war and we treat it like i think the
united states has never experienced a
war that's i think that's a problem on
our shores yeah yeah and when we do
we're shocked so we have a distorted
perception of what war is i think the
russians are much more realistic because
every russian is related to somebody who
was killed in world war ii right well
it's in their hearts it's seared in
and
you know i don't i can't speak for the
chinese but they lost like a couple of
million men in korea you know so they
they must have been some a lot of family
pain there
have you ever tried to calculate how
many people were involved
in the cover-up of the assassination
because you know when you break down all
the the various people that you document
um everyone from arlen specter to the
everyone that's on the warren
commission's report this it's very clear
that those folks had to know that what
they were doing was [ __ ] from what
you said about the fbi uh chain of
custody for the magic bullet to the the
alteration of the autopsy photos and the
difference between the autopsy itself
yes the autopsy itself the difference
between the dallas autopsy and the way
they looked at it at bethesda maryland
there was no autopsy in dallas it was
just
it was very quick the tracheotomy yeah
the tracheotomy and also the description
of the exit wound
in his head
well that yeah that comes out later yeah
although some people didn't see it but
40 people what the arb did thank god was
to collect all the people who saw the
rear exit wound and it was huge
we showed it in the film he showed the
40 people who saw it what's really crazy
document in the film was the fact that
it wasn't really his brain
that
was going to go to that yeah please the
brain that they had used as a piece of
evidence that this was kennedy's brain
had clearly been in formaldehyde for at
least two weeks yeah
well well i'm so glad our documentary
and this is james d eugenio who wrote it
you know he's really the guy who reads
everything remembers everything through
all these years and there's a million
documents
we drove a stake through the magic
bullet that's clear there's no chain of
custody of the fbi lied they also in the
in the matter of the autopsy that the
brain
is intact there's a and it was uh
photographed as such it was a clean
the whole area was still there whereas
it's impossible because the brain was
seen you see phil you see it spraying
spraying out in the car when there's a
pruder film
you see it the nurses audrey bell is
talking about it's
the it's
the the i can't remember the medical
term the whatever it's called it's
spilling out on the floor of parkland
yeah and when they weigh the brain as
they do in an autopsy it comes out
normal well not just normal but extra
large right a little bit larger than
average like it was
it's impossible and what's more
important is
and this drives at stake again to the
heart of the photographer of the autopsy
john stringer the autopsy photographer
he's he's a straight guy he's
you know pro warren commission all that
stuff they they bring them back the arb
brings them back and they
they show them the photos of that we now
have of the uh
that are in the national archives and he
says that's i never photographed that
right it was about he took an up view of
the brain he never took a basilar you
know from below
and i never photographed that
and that's very important there's also
some evidence that they had drawn hair
in to cover up the exit wound
yes
i know about the evidence but definitely
the photograph shows that the hair had
been pulled in
the shot is bizarre it's bizarre shots
but so the autopsy is off the brain is
off photos are off
then you go you know the garrison trial
revealed the one of the autopsies peter
fink
saying that there was the he they were
not in charge of the autopsy the
military was right he couldn't they
wouldn't let him put his finger in the
back hole right they they told them what
to do and they were very bullying in
fact
there was can you imagine having doing
an autopsy on the president and having
20 or 30 people looking at you from a
gallery and they were telling him what
he was able to do and not able to do so
the autopsy was being directed yeah i
showed that in the movie don't touch
that right
don't do that which is you so you have
to think that plus they have fifth they
have the best autopsy people in the
world civilian all around washington why
didn't you why don't why wouldn't they
call them in no right there's no desire
so they had a predetermined
ending that they wanted to achieve
or a result that they wanted to achieve
three bullets three blocks one assassin
but this is what's crazy is like you've
got to think okay when then you have at
least those 30 people that are in the
the audience watching that autopsy how i
mean what do they know
i don't know that but isn't that crazy
if all 30 of them know that lee harvey
oswald didn't act alone no we don't know
that we don't know right i mean we don't
know some of them but they there's
there's obviously a directive
well now there again no we don't know i
shouldn't say obviously directed but
they're they're doing something
to influence the way this autopsy is
being done at least some of the people
are giving direction giving instruction
and you gotta wonder why would they do
that like what motivation would they
have unless they knew that there was a
predetermined result that they need to
achieve you have of course the johnson
fear that it would get it become a
hysteria
russia or cuba being accused of killing
him and it would be a situation that
they could no longer control that's a
legitimate excuse to cover up
you know one interesting story it's in
the four-hour version not in this
two-hour version that's coming out in
the end of february
in that we show a moment in the uh
autopsy where one of the technicians
what the doctor looks up he says there's
cigar smoke
blurring this thing it was just cigar
smoke smells
covers up the the air and stuff it looks
you don't do it you don't smoke a cigar
and you know it turns on tops of
christmas
who's doing that find out dylan put it
out he goes over to the gallery and
guess who's smoking the [ __ ] cigar
who general curtis lemay
the the figure from strange love that
kubrick was satirized hilarious and he
says can you put it out you know lemay
simply looks at him
blows smoke in his face
and the guy wrote he was a you know
technician he just wanted he told the
truth walks back couldn't get him to put
the cigar on wow that's pretty
interesting